a traveler
comes upon the statue of an emperor
inscribed with the words my name is
azamendius king of kings
look upon my works and despair
only there's nothing left beside it
except
empty desert
it is good to be back i really wish
they'd let us play music up here why
because we'd already be on our feet
ready for action
we have considered your request for
passage through our territory and we
will not stop you but do not expect us
to save you kayla's [ __ ] pursuing
exploration always carries risk
i say we risk it everything forbidden is
sweet this is a good day it is a good
day
you do know where you're going right
nope oh boy
let's go make some history i didn't
prepare anything just speak from your
heart
we're about to enter unexplored space i
know you're all just as excited as i am
so let's give this everything we got and
may the force be with you
how was that perfect
we've served together
we've laughed together
and we all owe each other our lives you
will surrender or you will die
and it's a very special thing we should
all get big bonuses this is
history in the making
years to a better future i will be sure
to bring my what does lieutenant malloy
call it
my a-game there you go buddy
we have to find a way to preserve some
kind of peace
humans have a tendency to reduce things
to black and white good and evil
we can find a way to coexist you're
kaylon your people would like to see us
all dead
after all these years you're still able
to surprise me show the galaxy that
humans are different that we value life
even when our enemies don't captain you
are being deceived
[Music]
it's almost like yesterday was one life
and today's another
and everything's different on this side
of time
definitely worth the wait
[Music]
hello
i'm adam i'm one of the doctors what
kind of a doctor doesn't matter what
kind
this is
also known as brats and [ __ ]
you're generally sailing the ship alone
a ship that's massive and on fire and no
one's had the time to teach you how to
sail you pull the babies out so there
aren't any more babies to pull out
but what other doctors can say they end
up with twice the number of patients
they started with
what do we do now
i think you have to feed it for a few
years let it live in your house and then
send it to school
sorry
i wasn't great on my first week either
i've been here two months
you can do this i can't do this
i just feel so constantly overwhelmed so
you're just gonna not let it get to you
stiff upper labia right
i live with harry i'm very happy and we
love each other and we're gay both of
you
doing anything fun tonight i thought i'd
go home three hours late get shouted out
and fall asleep on the toilet
doctors nurses
they don't do this for the money they do
because they care
why do you care because it reflects very
badly on me if you die
[Music]
so let me say it again cam i may be a
superhero but i'm also just a man who
fell in love with the wrong woman just a
man who fell for the wrong woman
for the wrong woman
i am very excited for everyone to meet
the real me
there's something wrong with homelander
there's something broken
he's lost his [ __ ]
we've been on the straight and narrow
all year
no killing soups no drinking
even follow hugh campbell's orders
without strangling him
now you're just being cruel or maybe
you're not such an [ __ ]
but real power
isn't this
it's the ability to bend the world to
your will
[Applause]
the gloves are off
i thought we could fight about the right
way but we can't it's all rigged we have
to do it your way
we're all we've got it's up to us
i think i have something
[Music]
maybe we can use it to blow homelanders
[ __ ] brains out
what's this makes you a soup for 24
hours
you're gonna need it
[Music]
the whole point of what we do is that no
one should have that kind of power
for once i level the [ __ ] playing
field
i show people
the real me
i mean they [ __ ] loved me
[Music]
christ soldier boy
[Music]
get a good look honey allow me to
present to the titular body behind body
by sheila that is a dynamite looking
outfit what's that color
yellow eyes on the prize
i would love to expand into my own
lifestyle brand stick to the plan
i want you to go out there and promote
your film it's a videotape whatever it
is he doesn't care
i'm the original heart you stole from me
no this is my routine
what do we say about that anger of yours
then it's bad vibe super bad vibes
i am committed to growing my business
you have a following but i don't have
this
are you marching are you breathing
i control my own name i control my own
business
and nobody tells me what to do or say
brother would you want to go into
business with me i just have one
condition no more secrets
what secrets
she took everything
then let's take it back
change is
growth
but so is loss
pain
regret this wasn't going to work sheila
it's none of your business it's actually
half my business
[Music]
what kind of person thinks they can
behave in this way
are you here to work for me or to try to
become me
sheila's rocket ship is about to take
off
i'm tired of playing defense
so what's your goal
reciprocity
a retribution
[Music]
we've been in annihilation long i was
just starting to worry though relax i
mean you think they'd sell these things
if they weren't safe
yeah that makes sense
[Music]
make sure you roll up your windows
you don't want to get wet
keep your hands on the wheel cause uncle
chris's girl's gonna take you down to
the valley child
the governor of mississippi has just
announced that lockdown will end next
week
you ready for that grand rick rick
riot man hey
you can't throw a rock without hitting
five businesses it ain't closed down
oh y'all best appreciate what i've been
doing these past five months keep on and
this booty gonna be gone so finally we
get to see your last dance huh
i'm auditioning for some new girls
beyonce need her kelly and michelle
the best we had are gone i ain't no
coach you are actually
okay
i suggest you follow my lead
i want you to remember how you even got
in the position to buy this club
oh y'all thought the pink had done her
last dance but this a whole new day a
whole new painting
[Music]
we all need a little hell in our lives
it makes you appreciate the lie i'm a
classy even classy to be pronounced
ain't no use in being the richest in the
graveyard
[Music]
paint the walls red
blood stains always bleed back through
[Music]
i'm so sick of being a superhero but
blockbuster just let you make movies you
love
i'll be irma vet this is the part she's
been dying to play i told her not to get
involved with those people what else can
i do
[Music]
how's it been gone are you happy mira
i'm never happy
who would have thought that you would
end up working with him
grenade's crosses can be confusing
[Music]
they're a stranger
in a strange town
you play tough but you're so candid
i'm young
i'm a movie star
i like when they look at you what
matters is staying sane
[Music]
[Music]
okay so first off i just want to say
i get it
you get what
high school
kamala kamala another adventure shirt
cute she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo
you were a weirdo boys excuse me yeah
you're kind of on my shirt sorry
but you're staring at the window in your
little fantasy land
kamala hey already really come on like
do i have to figure out my whole future
before launchers it's like
[Music]
maybe they're right
i spend too much time
and fantasyland
that is not to you
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city
you save the world
that's a fantasy too
did something happen to you no why did
you hear something come all out
what does it feel like
cosmic
i always thought i wanted this kind of
life
[Music]
but i never imagined any of this
do you know what you are
i'm a superhero
[Music]
haven't seen you around you a tourist
nah i've been in baltimore for med
school oh actually i dropped out hot
smart and afraid of commitment every gay
man's type
honey what are you doing here i lost my
keys wow you love a dramatic entrance
daddy's home
hi girl how are you feeling i'm kind of
nervous i've never performed on like a
real stage before i really want this
thank you mom
hey
the best way to get over someone is by
getting under someone else
[Applause]
give me
who are you you don't remember what
happened
since that night this entire part of
myself that made me feel okay is gone we
cannot do this without you ruthie
would you want to like hang out
[Music]
all of us survivors struggle every g
damn day if one more person calls me
brave hey
i'm gonna kick them full on actually not
survivors hey hey hey stop thrivers
okay never mind he's trash
[Music]
you gotta stop blaming other people for
your problems
we gotta take control of our lives again
this is how it should be honoring the
victims
mingus has told me so much about you and
by so much i mean he's been really cagey
mom can you stop please
[Applause]
what does someone wear to a sex party
tonight remember our friends not as
similar but for the messy ass plus
you ready to play cheek
what in the game help you know what
that's called healing
i want to feel alive again
whoa whoa whoa whoa
are you gay
[Music]
there's a primal urge in all of us to
explore
[Music]
some say private citizens have no
business of space exploration i
emphatically disagree we have a historic
opportunity the first mission to mars
nasa's joining helios and the soviets a
three-way race to mars we're not going
to come in second place again to anyone
we're talking about discovering life on
another planet it'll change our concept
of who we are where we're going
[Music]
the massive dust storm has obscured both
landing sites years even decades of
planning comes down
to this moment
we're landing blind
brings for impacts
being first is what it's all about
this is the resource that can support
large-scale human colonization
want to tell us where the water is
the survival of my crew depends on
[Music]
when united behind a common goal there
is nothing we cannot achieve
[Music]
it's only the beginning
[Music]
i'm from a lineage thousands of years
old of the best monster hunters to ever
walk the earth
even on good days i feel like i still
don't fit in
like everyone else has it all figured
out
oh yeah that i haven't told anyone of
course
you are a legacy vampire made vampires
with love see their reflection in a
mirror
we're hunters
more importantly you're my daughter
which is why we've decided you're ready
for your first kill used to killing
monsters
your body is changing my body but very
soon you are going to have to make your
first kill
[Music]
it's juliette right yeah you're calif oh
cow's good
who are you collide where'd you come
from
addicted to lavanya how does it feel
you're nothing like the monsters i grew
up hating i just want to live my life
you can't be together it won't work i've
forbidden you from seeing her
we're not supposed to be i know my
feelings for you are real julia and
every legacy in savannah dies tonight
run now
keep your things in your mouth we won't
have a problem we will always have a
problem
i had to choose between you and my
family
i choose my family
what about us
faced everyone monster and human who
tried to come between us
we got this
i'll kill for you
are doing this
okay
i want you david
i want you more than anyone i've ever
[Music]
it's all so still
hello
[Music]
[Music]
it's a short slide
praise jesus
[Music]
[Music]
hi there it's all so quiet
two people were murdered at the motel
last night
with the scene there
should just
be
you got a visitor lieutenant i'm your
new deputy you know about this
looks like you guys could use the help
nice suit
thanks you look like pat boom
what are you going to do search 27 000
square miles
hello
[Music]
did you catch you did it no yeah
so no leads no idea who may have done
such a terrible thing
you hear about this armored car robbery
eyewitnesses place that hijacked chopper
headed into navajo country i thought we
were talking about a double homicide
we're talking about both
anna died of cardiac arrest she was 20
years old the coroner said that she was
scared to death
i promise you i'll find who did this to
her
so with this but she's blind what you
have to say there might have been two
men
we cracked this case
seeketh and ye shall find death saith
the lord
[Music]
i saw something last night
it was real
[Music]
real is in the eye of the beholder
[Music]
what's happening father door
why did you bring us all here the king
is dead
long live the king
[Music]
others will always seek to use us you me
and our brother
they wish us to fight it out to the
death and hope they're standing behind a
winner at the end
the world wants us to dance
the king feels that it's time for you to
get married rich frederick is about your
rage you're pretty craving power
princess we'll have to keep an eye on
you put your eyes back inside your head
so thomas is a fine man the way you
behave with elizabeth
everyone thinks i'm a full tour of
marriage
a woman's family arranges her marriage
louder you protest the more you fracture
an already fractured country
don't make me edward please a king can't
change his mind just because you want
him to
you think i've ever got what i've wanted
you're a princess exactly
[Music]
the country is at war
not just with scotland and france but
with ourselves
your brother might have his pawn in the
game
but i have mine
this great game of keeper killed
who will not be killed
is it that you're a coward or is it that
you came unarmed to this fight
it's not the lion who hunts
it is the lioness
your brother is the king family is no
protection
but what do you want
it to return as i once was
[Music]
that girl is dead
[Music]
did i ever tell you about the first time
that i saw you
can we just go back to that perfect
moment you know start over
are you sure nothing's going on with you
ibrahim
[Music]
there was something between us i thought
we were friends and things got confused
i'm not your enemy benji well you're not
my friend i just thought if i acted like
everything was okay that
it would be
oh god and here's like oh my gosh it is
too early for this awkwardness i want to
be upfront and uh let you know i'm
seeing someone lard
actually wow that's so great i'm
actually dating someone too wow okay who
who's who's the lucky guy
it's lucy i'm dating lucy
surprise wow that is that is so great i
mean i'm so happy for you for us for all
involved stop talking i'm trying i can't
i knew that i lost you
i don't feel great lying to your parents
after the first few times you get used
to it
everyone thinks that high school
romances have an expiration date
i think we are bigger than that
i know we are
i guess it just made me really sad
really saying goodbye
if you and i are gonna have any real
chance of working out then i have to
figure my problems out alone
everyone's like pressuring me to move on
i just don't know if i'm ready to yet
you're a good man miho maybe you and
nickel hit it off
[Music]
let's go see my mom
[Music]
being brave means that you aren't afraid
to be scared
because a lot of the times the scariest
things are also the most important
like admitting who you love
or who you are
i did download that dating app you told
me about no way hold on let me find a
torso pick that looks like you don't
mind my phone is like 99 shirtless
selfies of course it is of course it is
11 teams 11 dreams
with all eyes on the lcs trophy with
greatness
comes high expectations
i don't have regrets
[Applause]
i'm proud of my legacy
esports is one of the biggest sports in
the world
when most fans think about fugitive
gaming they think of one name
and that's cream cheese i put them right
up there with best all time i've played
in huge arenas got a ton of girls i
bought a porsche cream cheese has a bit
of a reputation for being hey hey hey
buddy annoying
back when cream cheese started playing
players didn't have million dollar
contracts girls didn't think we were hot
you know not in the way they do now in
2015 we started team fugitive together
you want to be team fugitive you got to
go hard we were kind of the bad boys
we never claimed to be role models we're
going to the lcs honestly we'll probably
win seven championships
he never met the expectations that he
set for himself
i need to win a championship it's just a
matter of time until cream cheese is no
longer the face of the franchise because
fans are ready for the era of organism
your son can be the face of the entire
sport he wanted to play with fugitive
i've been watching cream cheese for so
many years now i'm suddenly right next
to him so you're you're a prodigy dude
it's like standing in front of one of
those kids who plays the piano you know
he was so obsessed with the game that he
didn't want to waste time going to the
bathroom people used to call him pj pj
let's go pj
it's for piss jar
he's gonna be the youngest pro player in
north america it was so dope uh and then
he took my job they want to see organism
start you cannot do this to us i can't
play with him
i've been here for five years you've
been here for five minutes
organ doesn't pop up in the middle into
the middle cream cheese just wants
people to listen to cream cheese do you
not click so wow everyone was dying to
know how organisms game would translate
to the pros organisms started walking up
to this purple worm thing looked like
grimaces from mcdonald's and he died and
everybody started cussing them out
we were all wondering if this big bet on
a kid
with no team experience would pan out or
would it be a colossal failure i don't
have that much time left
[Music]
[Music]
hello hey kid it's me they found me
dad are you okay yeah i'm fine the dogs
are fine
i thought i covered the tracks
you and i were not gonna be able to talk
again
remember that i love you then i'll
always love
you i'm on a plane to morocco tomorrow
what is happening i want to understand
how your world works
come with me i'll tell you everything
[Music]
[Music]
i know what started all this
this thing's been buried in the ground
for 30 years i wanted it to stay there
this is not something to underestimate
any more you send it ma'am send them
back in bags
anyone you send to my kid send them back
in pieces what
there's a villain in every story
nobody ever sees themselves as playing
that role
you have no idea what i did who i was
there's no limit to the damage he'll do
or the things he'll destroy
it matters to me what happens to you
after this it matters to me that you
make it out alive somebody's got to keep
an eye on the world the way he does
or the game the way he does
what i'm built for
is defending things
defending
all the best things i've done in my life
have been a service in that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
our mother built an empire
we fought
and we've killed
to defend it
we need to start fresh
one last job
how much five million dollars well
there's showtime
there's a cop looking a pope he was the
last person to see katherine bellen
alive
things go wrong
could be trouble for the whole family i
need to know that you have my back
people are coming for your weak family
we'll figure it out
we always do
i'm just gonna deal with it and pretend
they'll never happen
it did it
we buried enough family this needs to
end
animal kingdom the final season june
19th on tnt
this isn't your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy this is the sparrow
academy
shares
[Music]
when we jumped here we created a time
paradox our little paradox brought forth
the freaking kugelblitz what the hell is
the cougar blitz essentially we're
screwed
[Music]
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] who can fight
next person to say [ __ ] is getting a
punch to the throat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing things
how long do we have four maybe five days
before the rest of existence is blitzed
not to mention we've been replaced by a
bunch of blobs and cubes and birds and
[ __ ]
your team is good but i don't think
you're better than me
i entered the world twice
and you you're just meeting spandex
dad didn't adopt us as babies but those
babies still existed here so if you ever
see your other self kill them sleep with
them avoid them the hell is wrong with
you oh come on as if you wouldn't climb
luther mountain
[Music]
if i kill you do we get our bent back
what the hell did you just say
what are you their mascots
more like their ringer
[Music]
spoiler alert
25 pounds no no i ordered 200.
what is beef we still got that meat
connected
we get 12.50 for that on ebay boom
you cut vegetables like a [ __ ]
that system system basis the system
this is your brother's house i was
running it fine without you why didn't
you leave it to you then
don't wipe your hands on your apron chef
jess i refer to everybody as chef
because it's a sign of respect you could
throw down huh
behind behind so how are you gonna pass
the family test delicious or impressive
delicious is impressive where
yo family's up i just never had plaster
nose with like grass on them
we want to change this restaurant right
but we have to change the chemistry yes
chicago are you always like watching me
that's just sort of my job we're the
chili flakes cause it organizes it's
more confusing right there
label chili flakes
this is a delicate ecosystem and it's
held together by a shared history and
love
i have every intention of turning this
into a respectable place of business
eventually
time to try the new sandwiches yo this
[ __ ] looks different what do you think
it's redundant in white just like you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
morning
you look like you seen a ghost
[Music]
you
becky
i know chloe
but we haven't spoken for years
i think she was in some kind of trouble
you got that look your brain is spinning
just knitting like what was going on
with her
not getting answers to your questions is
a really hard thing
your membership number i'm in a bit of a
rush do you mind if i head in now oh
yeah
sorry i'm sasha oh i'm olivia
this is sasha by the way i know sasha
what is going on becky i'd just like to
decide how people see me
so how do you know liv we're yoga
friends
why are we having dinner with strangers
his wife died and we're here as if
nothing has changed
how did it happen suicide
becky i need your help
i just thought i knew what her life was
but i completely wrong
did you speak to her that night you ask
a lot of questions about chloe
you like the thrill of it don't you
you don't really know
me back
off
dug myself into a bit of a hole
i know she's gone
i feel like i'm cheating
[Music]
why do you think she did it
[Music]
who are you
i'm sorry
what happened to chloe
[Music]
just a perfect day
drink sangrea in the park
and then later
when it gets dark we go home
[Music]
just a perfect day
[Music]
feed animals
[Music]
just a perfect day
you made me forget myself
i thought i was someone else
[Music]
you just keep me hanging on
you just
keep me hanging on
[Applause]
you're going to reap
just what you saw
you're going to reap
just watch
you